hi this is Mario with Mario's math
tutoring in this video we're going to
talk about how to use the triangle
proportionality theorem in geometry so
we're going to talk about what the
theorem is and then we're going to talk
about a couple of examples so first of
all when you look at the triangle okay
and you draw a line okay that's parallel
to the base okay it doesn't have to be
in the middle it doesn't have to be like
a mid segment it just has to be parallel
to the base what happens is it ends up
splitting these two sides into two
pieces okay sometimes it's called the
side splitting theorem because of that
right so it's just you know cutting this
basically into two parts and then the
ratio that we can use this proportion
that we can use is that the ratio of A
to B is the same as the ratio of C to D
so I've simplified it sometimes in
textbooks they you know they make a
little bit more complicated so I'm just
calling this a and B C and D and the
ratio of this part to this part is the
same as this part to this part so let's
go through a couple examples so first of
all you can see that this little arrow
represents these two line segments are
parallel and we know that the ratio of
nine to X let's write that down nine to
X is the same as six to two okay so
that's our proportion all we have to do
to solve is we can cross multiply across
the equal sign right 9 times 2 is 18 6
times X is 6x divide everything by 6
both sides write x equals 3 and you got
it so it's pretty straightforward let's
look at example number two now this one
is kind of using the triangle
proportionality theorem in Reverse like
the converse of the proportionality
theorem and it says you know is BC this
line segments parallel to de we don't
know because we don't see these arrows
here to indicate that it's parallel so
let's go ahead and set up a proportion
and see if in fact the ratio of five to
one is the same as four two point eight
right well let's double check so what we
can do you can either divide these and
see if they're the same or you can cross
multiply again and see if these cross
products are the same so 5 times 0.8 is
4 and 4 times 1 is 4 so yes indeed BC is
parallel to de and we've shown that so
again review the formula if you need to
triangle proportionality theorem it's
pretty straightforward the main thing is
that this
segment is parallel to the base and you
got it so subscribe to the channel check
out more math tutoring videos on my
youtube channel Mario's math tutoring
and I look forward to helping you in the
future videos I'll talk to you soon